les bateaux derrière de base qui va le
croire c'est peut-être là c'est beau sur
l'équipe est partie
au lycée c'est plus ou moins bien
que je le savais pas ce qu'il va passer
derrière du nan'ao bah ouais aujourd'hui
un peu béat rien à faire les empêcher
tout seul
hors norme
c'est clairement prêt à tous les rendez
sur
poursuivre en plus hors de l'eau à la
retraite super pouces
pensez un peu trop motivés par l'enjeu
quel culot
c'est super beau se regarde comme c'est
joli mais j'adore
au sein
mais pas un peu sombre non
franchissement
parfois sombre je suis en train de
compter
donc bien comme ça vient du père
ce rapport est la peau
avant ça peut entendre
des champions
beaucoup ont péri donnera dans un train
d'en attendre mais s'il te plait je
descends je tape touche bon
en faisant fonctionner ce n'est pas le
dr de l'argent
lancement d'une femme fatma
sur le pont
un
plateau derrière qui fait
pas trois mois de ce superbe aux morts
j'adore cette grande pointe
où
par la tournée vise à sortir d'abord eu
des rapports avant
oui
avec un choc
donc le problème